Yo, Jidai. I know at least five Muslims
that would be down to debate you on the
Quran. I would debate you, Korah would
debate you, Itachi would debate you,
Libyano would debate you, Central would
debate you. Nobody's scared of you, bro.
You're a weasel. You're so easy to
debate.
Oh, here she is. What's going on? Talia.
What's up? Hi. Okay, nice chance. And
you can state your position again, but
if I if I am misattributing something to
you, I'm saying something wrong, then
you just correct me. But basically, you
take the position that all of these
readings go back to Muhammad, and that
these are all inspired, they're all
revealed, and that they're all correct.
>> Right. Yeah, my position
>> so what I'm trying to say, all 10 of
them, right?
Yeah, the 10 are from the prophet peace
be upon him. Okay. So yeah, so what I'm
trying to demonstrate is that this view
of the different readings that you
Muslims have today has definitely
evolved throughout history, and that the
early Muslims that we can trace back and
who talked about this, actually took a
very very different view, and they
didn't believe that these, specifically
those 10, all of these 10 were correct,
or that they were all going back to
Muhammad, that they're all inspired. And
the one that we're bringing up as an
example is chapter 1 verse 4, King of
the Day of Judgment versus Owner of the
Day of Judgment. So when we go to
al-Tabari, you'll see that he comments
on this, and he talks about the reading
of King. So so Malik, the King, is the
correct of the two. It's the he says the
most authentic reading, the most
authentic reading in his in his opinion.
And so when I see that, I want to get
your What do you think he means when
when he says that, the most correct
reading? Okay, I'm currently reading the
page right now. So when I start this
off, I'm going to say I have not read
this entirety of the page that we're
quoting right now, so I can't
necessarily have a stance on it until I
read it. So
>> Okay, that's that's fair. That's fair.
And by the way, if if you have one that
you've read and you've done you've done
more research on, we can go to that one,
[snorts] because I don't want I don't
want to like make it come off like I'm
bombarding you with something or like
I'm trying to come at you with something
that you don't know about. I want you to
take one that you have read about before
and we can go we can use that as an
example instead. Yeah, I was just like I
mean as you said we're going back to the
city mama double D. So the people in the
chat can get a gist of what we were
talking about now. Exactly. All right.
So this was an example that you actually
brought up, right? Cuz I asked you to
show me Yeah, okay, cool. So this is one
that you brought up. All right, so you
can as you know it's in front of you
it's a long one. It's very long, but
there's a section when he kind of gives
his conclusion and he says that the the
first reading which is the reading of
king is the most correct reading of the
two. And then he gives you the reasons
why. He says that when you use the
reading of king it has the meaning of
sovereignty and it describes to God
exclusive sovereignty and over the over
the word owner or or he says that you
know, he gives you an example. He says
that it's known that there's no king
without him having It's known that
there's no king without him being an
owner, but an owner may not be a king.
So he's saying is that if you're king
you're automatically an owner, but if
you're an owner you're not necessarily a
king. So that's why he chooses this
reading of king and he thinks that it
gives more glory to God and it's
a exalt more exalted view of God. And he
actually gives more reasons than that,
but we can just deal with those right
now. Yeah, of course. I'm going to if I
if I need to get off the panel or
anything like that I'm going to read
through this of course cuz It's a long
mama
double D. I've never read this stuff
before in English before cuz I have the
book I have the book, but it's in
Arabic. Okay. And I'm more I'm more
familiar with English than I am in
Arabic cuz I grew up in the West and
stuff. So I've never read this in
English before. So I'm I'm not familiar
with this. Okay. That's that's fine. I
don't know I think there might be
English translation available somewhere,
but it costs like a ton of money. I
think but the Arabic is you know
accessible. You can get it online or Or
have the book for it you said you said.
So, you can check it out. Of course, of
course. Okay.
So,
we're wrapping up the validity now.
Okay. So, I where we left off is the
chains of narration and you brought up
Hafs, right?
That was the first variant that you
brought up in the chain of narration.
So, can you go ahead and present your
argument against Hafs? Specifically
about about the Hafs reading. So, not
just Hafs, but the reading as a whole.
So,
okay. So, so when we look at the chain
for Hafs and you were reading it
earlier, you might still have it. It
goes Hafs and then he learned it from
Asim and then Asim learned it from Abi
Abdur-Rahman and then he learned it from
Uthman, Ali, Zaid, Ubayy. They learned
it from Muhammad and you know, Muhammad,
Gabriel, etc. etc. to Allah.
And so, when you when you apply the
method that Muslims applied for this
chain of
for the science of men that they call
it, that they grade like who's an
authentic person for Hadith, who's
trustworthy for Hadith, they have like
four different criterion for like how
they judge someone's reliable. So, the
first one is Islam, like they have to be
Muslim. And then they have the second
one they have to
they're like a legally responsible age
or they're an age where they considered
to be responsible. The third one is
academic proficiency and the fourth one
is moral integrity. And each of those
have like subcategories. What makes you
someone like with moral integrity? You
have like a bunch of different rules and
criterion for what makes you morally you
know, and it's the more a moral person
basically. So, you need to you need to
fit all four of these things for Hadith
to be a reliable Hadith narrator. Now,
when we apply that standard those
standards for the Quran, the readings of
the Quran, we see that they fall short
on a lot of different readings. A lot of
a lot of the readers
aren't considered to be reliable in
Hadith. And because there's not like a
science of for you know narrators for
the Quran in the same way that there's
one for the Hadith. You have to just
apply what you have available. So, if
you have scholars writing about these
same people, the same individuals when
it comes to Hadith, then you apply it to
the readings of the Quran and you'll see
that it makes a big problem. So, I just
as an example, and I think you
acknowledged this earlier, but Hafs is
called unreliable in the Hadith and a
number of reasons are given. One of the
reasons is he he was a thief. He was
considered to be a liar and
untrustworthy for for those reasons. And
these are like big scholars who call him
things. Like Al-Bukhari for example says
he's rejected. Big big scholars say
this. So, the argument here is that the
chain of narration that you guys have
for the for the Quran, if we apply the
Hadith criticism or the method of what
makes them reliable for Hadith onto
someone for the Quran, then these people
wouldn't even pass for Hadith. So, how
do they pass for Quran? Okay, perfect.
So, you're done? Yeah. Yeah.
I'll tackle all of your points one by
one if that's okay. So, I'm going to
start with the qualifications of whether
or not Imam Hafs is reliable in Hadith
and whether or not we can
cross-reference this into how reliable
he is when it comes to Quran. Does that
make sense? Okay.
I'm going to start with that. So, do you
know the name of the person who
criticized Hafs and called him a liar?
Yeah, there's a whole list of There's a
whole list of them.
Um, I'll just give you Yeah.
Specifically, um,
Ibn Kharrash
was one of them. Yeah.
>> start with that if you'd like. Okay, go
ahead.
Okay, Ibn Kharrash, he's he's the man
that called Hafs a liar, right? Yeah,
one of them, yeah. Okay, Imam
al-Dhahabi mentions in his in a book
that scholars like Abu Zur'ah
Zur'ah, sorry, said Ibn Khirash is a
Rafidi and others mentioned that he gets
a mursal narration and he would make it
connected and lie to fabricate it and
make it connected and he would say
something mawquf, mawquf, sorry, from a
companion and make it marfu' from the
prophet. So, the person who calls or the
person that you specifically mentioned,
Ibn Khirash, who called Hafs a liar, is
not reliable. He's called a Rafidi and
he's also accused of making chains that
are mursal reliable and attributing them
to the prophet, peace be upon him.
So, that's the the first point. So, when
we're talking about hadith, which
obviously
>> Okay.
Wait, wait. So, do you do you disagree
that there are scholars, hadith
scholars, that call him a liar?
Because I can have a I can give you a
response to that, but I just want to
know if you agree that there are hadith
scholars who call him a liar. No, I'm
not I'm not denying that other scholars
call him a liar. It's just that's the
first name that you brought up, so I
decided to mention that first person.
Okay. So, let's just deal with the
scholars that you accept that call him a
liar. Sure.
Like Yahya bin Ma'in, for example.
Uh do you know what book, right? Do you
know what book he quotes that in? Uh
yeah, I have I have all the information
in front of me, actually. Yeah, of
course.
>> yeah, so
actually, do you want the Do you Do you
want the the book names or do you
>> Go for it. How do I give it I don't know
how to give it to you. I mean, you can
you could type it in chat, you can say
the book name and I can try and find it.
Whichever works for you best. So, are
you are you aware of him calling him a
liar or do you or do you just not aware
you need the reference to verify it? Oh,
I'm aware. I just want the reference.
Okay. Wait, wait, hold on. So, what Why
do you want the reference if you know he
called him a liar? Because, what is it
called? I need to fact check that
reference. Okay, but you agree that he
called him a liar.
I agree that the reference that you're
talking about says that he's a liar.
Yeah. But okay, so anyway, so yeah, you
can
it's from Ahmad bin Muhammad
al-Baghdadi. He said that Ibn Ibn Ibn
Ma'in said that Hafs was a liar. Okay.
And Abu Bakr Abu Bakr was more
trustworthy. Uh ooh.
Okay. Uh you said uh
Ahmed ibn Muhammad al-Baghdadi? Ahmed
bin Muhammad al-Baghdadi, yeah. Okay,
perfect, perfect. Ooh, okay.
>> So anyway, so so this is just uh you
know, one of the
>> I wanted to address that point as well
if that's okay. Okay, but but you agree
that he called him a liar, right? Hold
on, wait. Yeah, I I agree that it says
in the book that you quoted that he's
called a liar, but I want to address
exactly the reference that you're
talking about because I did find it and
I want to talk about it.
Okay, go ahead. Okay, perfect. Give me 1
second. So, we're talking about Yahya
ibn Ma'in calls Hafs ibn Sulayman a
liar, and I actually have the report
here in Arabic if we can look at it.
Okay. But, here's an issue. Do we Do the
question is, do we have any information
based on Do we have any information on
who Muhammad al-Baghdadi is? Do we know
if he is a good narrator? Do we know if
he's a liar? Do we know if he's
truthful? We don't have any information
on him.
>> Uh wait, well, what what do you think he
is?
You think he's just some some nobody
that's quoted in the book?
So, your scholars are just quoting a
nobody and attributing him to saying Abu
Ma'in uh
Abu Ma'in said that Hafs is a liar. And
you think they made it up and they they
they made it up and they
>> that is The narrator that is talked
about in this reference that you gave
me, we have no information on him, nor
do we know whether or not he is
credible. Which means we can classify it
as weak. I'm saying who is the scholar?
I'm saying No, no, no, you don't get to
classify classify this weak. Who is the
scholar that classifies it as weak?
Oh, 1 second.
Yeah. Yahya ibn Ma'in calls Hafs a liar,
but the issue is the report contains an
unknown man. Yeah, but who is saying
that though? Which scholar is saying
that? 1 second. Let me pull it up. Uh
Khatib al-Baghdadi doesn't even know who
he is in this reference here. I can pull
up the Arabic if you'd like. If anyone
in the chat can read Arabic. Historian
of Baghdad, Khatib al-Baghdadi, doesn't
even know who Muhammad al-Baghdadi is.
We don't know anything about him. Okay.
So, Abu Ma'in So, do you do you think
that Abu Ma'in didn't say that he's a
liar then? No, Abu Ma'in is talking
about a report that is reported by an
unknown man. No, no, no, no. Which this
is actually a common occurrence among
Abu Ma'in is Abu Ma'in is quoted as
saying that Hafs is a liar. Do you
disagree with that? Abu Ma'in is quoting
somebody who said that Hafs is a liar.
No, he No, he's being quoted. Okay,
perfect.
Let's Let's get it. Let's
>> Abu Ma'in is being quoted. Okay,
perfect. I'm going to pull up the
Arabic. Let's look at it. Sorry, let me
Forgive me. I actually
>> let me messed up. Let's do it. So, also
I want to show you other I want to show
you other um other Muslims who
acknowledge that Hafs is called a liar.
So, as you as you're pulling up the
Arabic for it and you want to look for
it, I want to show you Muslims who
acknowledge and admit that he's called a
liar. So, then the question will come
down to whether we should trust them or
trust what you say. Cuz these are what's
written in the books and Muslims are
acknowledging that. So, let me just pull
up that uh as you pull up the Arabic to
see what it says. Oh, also I have found
the Arabic. So, can I just read this
off? I'm going to try and translate it.
Go ahead.
Okay, so I already quoted uh Khatib
al-Baghdadi. But he actually wrote about
this in the history of Baghdad and it
says that it is an unknown factor that
there is
uh what is it called? That there is no
acceptance of reports with an unknown
individual, which means we can't accept
this.
Due to the fact that we don't know who
Muhammad al-Baghdadi is, we cannot
accept this report.
Yeah, I'm saying I'm saying who is who
is saying Yeah, who is saying this? Uh
Khatib al-Baghdadi in his book, The
History of Baghdad.
Okay, but this is not the This is not
the book that we're talking about,
though. No, no, this is a scholar
talking about the narrator that
the chain of Sorry, a narrator that
Yahya ibn Ma'in is quoting.
Okay.
And the book itself is no one in the
book I'm saying the off the scholar in
the book isn't saying that this is not
trustworthy.
Right? Mhm.
The scholar in the book is not
>> another You don't want someone else is
saying that.
No, no, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait,
wait, sorry. We're talking about
specifically Muhammad al-Bukhari.
Yeah, right. So, what I'm saying is
the book that has [snorts] um Ibn Ma'in
calling Hafs a liar.
That book doesn't say that this is not
trustworthy.
Oh, so we're only talking about uh Yahya
ibn Ma'in's book?
Or can we
>> Well, he or he's being quoted. That's
what I'm That's what I'm talking about.
Okay, perfect. No, cuz I was talking
about a different scholar that
classifies the narrator that is being
quoted as unknown.
>> Okay. Not specifically
Yahya ibn Ma'in. Okay.
So, I can Yeah, but that's what I'm
saying. I can give you other scholars
who's saying that yes, he is considered
to be a liar by uh Ibn Ma'in. And not
just him, by the way. He's He's just one
He's just one. So, do you Do you Are you
aware of all the reports that that he's
called a liar? Uh not all of them. Would
you like to enlighten me? Okay. So, um
yeah, let me just uh pull up another
example of it here. Uh how about the one
where he uh steals uh he steals books.
Are you familiar with this one?
>> Oh, I actually wanted to address this as
well. So, if you'd let me, I would love
to address this.
>> go ahead. So, just let me just um let me
just uh say read it first or get it pull
it up first. So, al-Bukhari is the one
who who narrates this.
And he says
that Hafs used to take people's books
and copy them and claim that they were
his own. And he would never return them
to the people. So, al-Bukhari was
discrediting him and saying this is why
he should be abandoned because he would
steal books, meaning a thief, and then
he would say that they're his own,
meaning he's a liar. Okay, perfect.
>> your response? Can I go ahead and
address this?
Yeah, please go ahead. You realize this
is a completely different Hafs, This is
talking about Hafs ibn Sulayman
al-Asadi, right? So,
uh Imam al-Dhahabi mentions Hafs ibn
Sulayman al-Asadi, right?
But the quote or not the quote, sorry,
the alleged that he stole books, it's
talking about a completely different
Hafs. Okay, are you sure about that?
Yes, I am. Okay. All right, so I I want
to make your point first before you
before you go ahead. You make your full
point. Okay, perfect. One second.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, sorry. I don't mean to laugh, but
I have it right in front of me and uh
it's not the it's it's it's it is the
same Hafs. But um go ahead. Go ahead,
make your point. Sure, sure, sure. I got
you. One second. Just give me a moment.
Do you have Do you have any Do you have
it or no? Yeah, I actually have notes on
this, so I'm looking through my notes
right now. Okay.
>> Okay.
Uh what I wrote, the claim that he stole
books is Okay, so the name of the man
who stole books was Hafs ibn Sulayman
al-Minqari
and not Hafs ibn Sulayman al-Asadi Abu
Amr al-Qani. Uh can you That's just my
claim. That's I I can present my
evidence in a second, but I was going to
let you finish if you can. Go ahead. Go
ahead. You present your evidence for it.
Okay, sure.
Um I'm trying to pull up the Arabic
first
Okay. instead of just my quotes. So, um
as you do that, let me just give you Let
me just play something here.
Uh this is an audio that you guys can
everyone can listen to.
Let me know if you can if you can hear
this. By the way, do you know do you
follow
YouTube like Muslims on YouTube?
Uh not really. I'm not really on any
socials or anything. I don't watch a
lot.
I don't really watch. I mostly read.
Okay, you don't you don't know who Farid
responds to or anything like that or Uh
I don't think so. No. I'm I'm not big on
watching YouTube. I just I I mostly
read, so. Okay, now this this won't be
helpful for you then. But just just for
the audience then, let me just play it
for them because they'll be familiar
with who he is. Okay, so so this won't
be meaningful for you because you don't
you don't follow these guys, but this is
a a Muslim YouTuber. So, I just want to
play what he says and you don't have to
interact with it because you don't if
you, you know, don't care to cuz you
don't you don't maybe you don't care for
him.
Um but let me just play. Anyone who
knows who Farid is, all all the Muslim
Dawah guys that are in the chat, they
know who Farid is. And listen to what he
says. Here we go. to the narration of
Hadith. So, like al-Bukhari said,
"Tarako." And also Muslim found Matruk.
But some scholars of Hadith also claim
that he was a Kadhab. So, how do we deal
with that? Good?
Like Ibn Khirash and others.
Yeah.
Okay. So, there are two
uh
or at least two people who who has
who has been attributed to that have
said that Hafs is a liar.
Um the first is Yahya ibn Ma'in and the
second is Ibn Khirash. That's the main
concern.
Um because Yahya ibn Ma'in is a major
scholar of Hadith. So, how was it
possible that this major scholar of
Hadith referred to Hafs as a liar?
Yahya said, "This Abu Omar is a liar."
referring to Hafs. Now, I want you to
keep a couple of things in mind here.
Firstly,
this statement
is actually
a statement in which he's saying that
Hafs' recitation is the best recitation
from Asim.
Okay?
Now,
imagine that. Imagine referring to
someone as a liar, but saying that his
recitation is the best recitation.
So, what does that mean? That means that
there are no specific issues with the
recitation of Hafs.
Listen to Okay. So, um anyway, like I
said, you don't have to respond to that
cuz you don't you don't probably don't
care what he has to say. But for all the
Dawah Muslims who are listening, all the
Dawah guys in the chat that know who
Farid is,
he takes the position that yes, he is
called a liar by this big, big, big big
Hadith scholar, but and then he tries to
explain it, you know, why it's
acceptable still. So, he is actually
called a liar and then later on in the
video he he gives a challenge and says,
"Okay, yes, he's called a liar, but I
want to challenge you to show me where
he lied." And that that's his challenge
for for the people. But but um yeah, but
you so yeah, you heard him referring to
uh anyway, you heard what he said. So
yeah, so now I can show you where
al-Bukhari when he's referring to Hafs
uh as someone who used books.
Um that this is the same Hafs. Uh
but you wanted to present evidence so
you can present your evidence before you
do that.
>> now I'm trying to find these books
instead of screenshots because my
screenshots are extremely blurry as I
showed. So, I'm trying to actually refer
to the actual book PDF, but Okay. you
can go ahead while I'm finding this one
book. It's it's a singular book. It'll
be It'll be quick. It'll be quick, but
uh I want to hear the rest of your
evidence if that's okay.
Yeah, yeah, sure. Um so, you have um
Hafs with you, right? Like the um the
the the isnad? Like do you have the
chain for it? Oh yeah, I do have the
chain. Okay. So, just again, just real
quick, um just read his name, like
Hafs's full name, just so I can uh be
sure cuz this is the same one here. I
just want to present this to you. Sure.
Yeah, yeah, let me just pull up the
chain for
uh his throat.
Yeah.
And you also heard you also heard um
Farīd there refer to him as Abū Ammar as
well. So, that's uh that's another
uh name that he has as well. But let me
just um let me just uh get this ready
while you uh confirm his name for us.
Uh Hafs uh ibn Sulaymān al- uh
al-Asadī.
Okay. Okay, perfect. So, uh God Logic,
can you give me uh the big screen real
quick, bro?
Thank you, man. Appreciate it.
Appreciate it. All right, here we go.
So, is this the same Hafs, right?
Uh uh Hafs ibn Sulayman is Abu Dhabi Abu
Abu Ammar. Okay. Okay. Yeah, now you can
read continue to read this hadith here
and you'll see the story here.
You know, he's uh narrating actually I
don't know how I can show you the full
thing. It's kind of uh
But anyway, this is the story. Let me
Let me go to the source.
Al-Bukhari
Okay. And he's talking about the same
Hafs right here.
And you can read it yourself. I'll just
kind of slowly kind of go by it. Can you
zoom out by the way?
Zoom out? Yeah, like can you make your
camera uh portrait not portrait mode?
Yeah, yeah, sorry. Like hold your phone
horizontally and zoom out. Oh, that
works better. Okay.
So, I'm trying to hold that still as I
can, but as you uh read it, I'll just
give So, this is the same story.
Um that a narration where Hafs used to
steal books
and uh that he wouldn't return them.
And uh
and then he would claim that they were
his own and he'd copy them for him like
say they're his own. So, in this story
we see uh when it's from Al-Bukhari by
the way as well, that Hafs, the same
Hafs that the Muslims get their Quran
from, the main majority of Muslims who
use his Quran today, that he's confirmed
here to be a thief, a liar,
and untrustworthy by Al-Bukhari.
Uh let's see.
I'm just trying to make it stable for
you. I know it's a little shaky, but you
can hopefully still read it.
>> do you know the Sorry, do you Do you
know the number and where this is
quoted?
Yeah, I'll give you the source. But
>> I can't read this It's it's a little
blurry by the way.
You want to screenshot it or you want to
write it down?
And then this book page 32.
And that's on uh
uh in Maktaba Shamila.
So,
we see there that Al-Bukhari is
confirming that this is actually the
same Hafs. That's why I wanted to
confirm his name. It's the same one and
uh let me just go back one more time.
Wait, can I ask what website are you
reading from?
Yeah, this website it's called
Al-Maktaba Al-Shamilah.
Like the you know like the
>> Al-Maktaba Al-Shamilah
Shamilah
Al-Shamilah
>> Yeah. So, if you just go to
shamilah.ws
Actually, I'll just show it on my screen
here. You can see. Yeah.
Okay, there we go.
Uh Shamilah Hold on one second. I'm just
going to
directly type this in so I can read
through this.
shamilah
.ws
.
dashbook
book/
2/
22 Yeah.
hashtag
and then P1
P1, okay.
Uh hopefully this
>> So, yeah.
So, you can go through it and you can
see and by the way, there were there
were actually um
other Muslims who who I know that you
don't I heard you saying that you don't
like sunnah.com because you think that
there's some Shia sources on there or
whatever, but they're actually Shia
Muslims who have done the same critique
on these different Quran authors as well
where they go through the Hadith science
and they see, okay, this is what makes
this person reliable, this is what makes
this person unreliable, and they would
take these names of these different
readers and they'd go through this
process and see, okay, what do these
scholars say about the trustworthiness
of this person? And then they go to the
next person, this person, and they came
up with all these problems. So, even
though the Shia they use the same like
Quran as you, they still actually came
up with these problems with this. So,
what I'm saying is it's not just
you know,
it's it's these are other Muslims who
are coming up with these issues as well.
They see this as a problem. Hold on.
>> You might not consider them Muslims.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, sorry. Wait, have you read through
the Arabic of this?
Wait, have you had it like any Arabic
speakers read through this? The book
that you're quoting. Yeah, why you don't
What's wrong with it?
Is there a problem with it in Arabic?
No, no, no, no, no. I was just asking
you, have you read through Have you
asked an Arabic speaker to read through
this?
>> Yeah,
I know a bit of Arabic. I'm in.
>> [gasps]
>> Nice. Okay, perfect.
So, anyway, you can read through it and
you'll see he's going through these
different different people. And when
he's at the Hafs
Okay.
What do you Do you want Do you want it
to be read in Arabic?
>> Wait, do you read Arabic? Yeah, yeah. I
Do you want to read it in Arabic? I can
have we can read it for you if you you
want in Arabic. It's not a problem.
Okay.
Um yeah, let me let me have it read for
you, okay?
Okay, perfect.
Okay. Hold on 1 second. So, let me just
put it on the screen and then we'll read
it. So,
do you Can you not read Arabic or do you
need someone to read it for you or
something or what?
>> I can read Arabic. It's just I take a
lot of time.
It wasn't my first language, but I can
read Arabic.
Okay, no problem. Okay, it says
>> [clears throat]
>> They left him.
Ahmed ibn Hanbal
Hanbal said
So,
Hafs ibn Sulaiman took a book from me.
And he didn't return it.
>> And he didn't return it.
And he used to take people's books and
write them, transcribe them.
Okay.
>> Is is that clear? Yeah, yeah. Do you
understand? Or Yeah, I heard her. I
heard
her perfectly fine. Can you ask her to
read the title of the book that you're
reading from from Al-Bukhari? Yeah, no
problem.
Uh
can you put it on the screen, brother?
Just so people know that it's the same.
Al-Saghir Al-Bukhari. So, the people of
um the book of the
weak people
>> Yeah, the the weak narrators, basically.
That that are listed from Al-Bukhari,
like his own
list of weak narrators or the weak
people.
I'm sorry.
So, uh anything else? Uh do you need
anything else from from the Arabic? Or
is
Uh I'm still trying to find my perfect
Not my perfect book, sorry. My clear
book
in Arabic so I can read from you and
show you how this is not the same exact
Hafs that you're talking about.
Oh, okay.
Um well,
I can show you the
So, his name is Hafs bin Sulaiman
al-Asadi. And then if you go to the
Quran,
you'll see that it's Hafs bin Sulaiman.
And it gives it gives his full name, but
it's al-Asadi al-Kufi, and it tells you
uh who we got who we got it from.
Yeah. We'll show
Hold on, let me show it to you.
Yeah, yeah. You can pull it up if you'd
like to, but you don't you don't have
to. I I think I know what you're talking
about.
Hafs
Hafs bin Sulaiman
It is.
Oh.
Al-Asadi al-Kufi. Oh.
So, it is the same Hafs, yeah.
Should I say something? Okay, 1 second.
What do you want to say?
No, no, I was talking to myself. Don't
worry, I wasn't talking to you.
Okay.
So, anyway, it's the same Hafs.
This the When you go to the isnad, it
gives you his fuller name. But, in in
Abu Hurairah, when he calls him Abu
Ammar, that you also heard Farid call
him that as well. Abu Ammar, that's you
know, like his
title, yeah.
Yeah, that's his kunya. His his like,
you know, that's his his oldest son's
name.
Ooh.
1 second.
So, so just
to be clear, what's the contention?
Because, if you want, we can give you
other sources where Muslims are saying,
"Don't take from him.
Don't take from Hadith." Like, I don't
Are you Are you actually contending that
he's reliable in Hadith, or are you
trying to say that he is?
>> I'm not I'm not trying to say that he's
reliable in Hadith. Don't worry. I just
wanted to go through your sources one by
one. That's what my intent was.
Not to argue that he was authentic or
not authentic, sorry, reliable in
Hadith. That wasn't my argument.
>> Okay.
So, when we
>> to move through your arguments one by
one by one.
Yeah, yeah, that's that's fine. And so,
so far,
you can see that he's I mean, let's just
stick stick with this one in itself.
This one in itself, he's called a liar.
Like, he basically, when you steal books
from someone, and you say that they're
your own, or you copy them for yourself,
say that they're your own, that means
that you're a liar. And then, also, he's
a thief as well, because he's stealing
books from people.
So. So, Jai, really quick, for the
audience that's listening,
why is this important of that amongst
the early Muslims and amongst the
scholars that Hafs is seen as unreliable
in Hadith and things of this nature. Why
is this important to Quran preservation
or recite his recitation of the Quran?
Exa- exactly. And by the way, it's not
just Hafs by the way because once you
get to Assim, Assim is also said to have
a weak memory to the point where you
have Muslim scholars saying, "Anybody
named Assim has a weak memory because of
how bad his memory was." Uh, he would he
went like senile and stuff and he just
was always forgetful. So, and then you
go to Abdur Rahman as well, who's next
in the chain, and you have a Hadith that
says he never learned the Quran from
Uthman.
He only learned it from Ali. But the
chain says he learned it from Uthman.
So, there's so many problems with this
chain. Why this is a problem is because
Muslims, they say that they have this
chain that connects them to Muhammad.
This Quran connects them to Muhammad.
They have this person who got it from
this person, who got it from this
person.
And when we go down the list and we see,
"Okay, actually this person, Muslim
scholars call him a liar. Muslim
scholars say he has bad memory. Muslim
scholars say he's unreliable."
When you go down the list, you'll see
that this chain that they have, they
would never accept a Hadith from this
person, Hafs. They would never accept a
Hadith from him.
But yet they they accept the Quran from
him? Wait, can I ask you a question?
>> Yeah, but but just here's the point
though. Here's Here's the major point.
Imagine that you don't accept Hadith
from somebody because they're a liar and
a thief. But yet you're going to accept
the word of God from them?
Like it's a much bigger thing that
you're trusting him with. If you don't
trust him in something smaller, why
would you trust him in something bigger
like the Quran?
>> Wait, can I ask you a question?
Yeah. Are there any scholars that
criticize Hafs in his Qira'at of the
Quran?
Uh, yes. Uh, yes, there are There are
There are some scholars who say that
Hafs would get things from himself and
he I even get it from his teacher,
actually.
Uh can you cite the source?
Okay. So, hold on because I feel like I
keep giving you sources, but we're not I
want to make sure we're getting
somewhere with this. So, I want to show
you one more, okay? I just want to show
you this this one more source from a big
big scholar who's very significant who
said that Hafs used to get some readings
from that he has from himself. He didn't
even get it from Awesome.
Okay? So, do you know who Abu Mujahid
is?
Uh I think so, yeah.
Okay. So, do you know what his
significance was?
Uh enlighten me.
Okay. So, he's the reason why you don't
have uh he's the reason Sorry, he's the
reason why you have the seven readings
of the Quran.
The Hafs?
What's that? The Hafs, like the seven
Oh, no no no no no. Ahruf, no no. Uh no,
the the Ahruf is a is a Hadith that are
not the same things as the Qira'at. So,
I'm talking about the seven
>> and Qira'at are different. There's 10
Qira'ats and seven Ahrufs, yeah.
Uh well, no. Uh later in history,
they're actually Ibn Mujahid added three
more, and so there's actually 10 There's
10 uh There's 10 readings There's 10
readings, like you said, but initially
Ibn Mujahid only canonized seven. So,
for a long period of of Muslim history,
like for like 500 years, there was only
seven readings. And because he chose
seven, because he chose the seven, and
he had the government to back him up on
this,
um
and they enforced his readings. They
even imprisoned people and uh tortured
them for rejecting his readings.
B- uh
he actually because of him, people
confused the seven readings with the
seven with the with the with the um
seven Ahruf.
Okay, okay.
Uh
>> So, let me just give you the source now.
So, the guy who The guy who canonized
Yeah, the guy who canonized um
the seven readings, Ibn Mujahid, said
that Hafs
was mistaken a number of times and he
actually specifically says that Hafs
I'll just give you one example where he
says that this reading that he got um
was from himself
>> [snorts]
>> and it didn't he didn't even get it from
Asim.
Uh did you say the source or
Yeah, I'm I'm going to give it to you
now. It's uh it's from Ibn Mujahid's
book. It's from his book. Um Kitab
al-Sab'ah fi Kitab um Kitab al-Sab'ah fi
al-Qira'at.
Yeah, let me let me show it to you. Let
me show it to you.
Yeah, the seven readings.
Okay?
Kitab al-Sab'ah fi al-Qira'at.
Ibn Mujahid. I know it's kind of blurry.
No, I can read it. It's It's good. Okay,
Ibn Mujahid. Okay, now now let me just
show you the reference now.
Um
Okay. So, just let me I'll just
highlight it. Hold on so you can see.
Because because you asked the question
like where did Hafs get things like just
where did he like kind of make mistakes
or something? Um oh no, this is not it.
Hold on. This is not it.
Okay, I'm just going to pull up the
reference for you now. Um were you still
looking for something that you wanted to
show?
Sorry, repeat that.
Were you still looking for something
that you wanted to show us? Not anymore,
bro. I can't.
Okay, no problem. Um
It's funny because I know what it says,
but I'm just trying to find it on the
page now.
Uh let me
see it.
Okay, for some reason I have I had like
two bookmarks for the same thing and uh
I was showing the uh
the wrong bookmark. So, anyway, here
here it is here.
Um
reference uh it's the same reference.
So, the same website as before. Um this
is the this the book like you know, you
have you already saw that. And then the
page is uh
What is that? 608?
Yeah, 608. Okay. And then here's here's
the reference here. So, page 608 in his
book. Um
It's saying
Qur'an Yeah, Qur'an Hafs. Yeah.
So, he he read it from himself, not from
Asim.
>> Yeah. But I'm not the daughter. So, he
put Adam on the daughter. Just from
himself.
>> exactly. And actually Ibn Mujahid
actually says that this is a mistake
because he says the it goes you know, he
said that he mixed up the verb with the
noun. But anyway, so Ibn Mujahid, the
one who who canonized, you know, the
reading
the readings
um, he actually said here that Hafs is
getting it from himself, not from Asim.
Even though
the you know, it's supposed to be from
Asim. He's not supposed to be making
stuff up on him on himself.
Ooh, wait, can you pull up the page
again if you don't mind?
What number from? Did you want the quote
or did you want like the page number or
what did you The page number.
Okay. I can't send links on here. I
don't know how to do that.
Uh yeah, what is that? 608?
Uh looks like uh Yeah, it looks like
six.
Yeah.
Oh, it's five.
Oh, it's six.
No, either I'm tripping or that's a
five. No. 508? Uh yeah, is it 508? I
don't know. Trying to figure it
Actually, I'll give you the link on the
top. Um, let me just uh do what I did
last time. I'll give you the link. Uh Of
course. Of course.
Ah, it's blurry. Hold on.
Okay, there we go.
You can screenshot that, maybe.
Got you. Got you.
What is it?
Thir- Okay, in the verse that he's
commenting on, it's chapter 30 verse 54.
30 verse 54. Okay, perfect. By the way,
I can no longer argue I can I can't
argue anymore cuz my laptop actually
died. That's why I can't pull up a
source anymore. Okay.
So
um
Yeah, so I don't know if you So you're
not able to continue with us then?
Do you want like a We can have like a
cliffhanger.
Yeah,
no problem. So so basically this
reference here is pretty clear that you
have like like a pops who's getting a
reading from himself not from Austin.
So this is obviously a big problem. And
so our whole point is that the way that
Muslims believe like what me and we're
saying in the other stream the other
live was that
the the whole idea of you guys' view of
preservation today is not
the the the the it's not the same it's
not the same as the early Muslims. So
we're trying to say that the view of
preservation that Muslims have
is not the same that early Muslims had
and in fact they didn't even believe
that
they might have believed that the Quran
was preserved but not in the same way
that you guys believe like word for word
letter for letter dot for dot.
And and by the way,
I don't want to introduce another topic
but we also talked about scribes like
scribes who would
apostatize from Islam because they
realized the same thing.
That that they would say something one
way and then Muhammad would say hey
that's what's been revealed and then
they he wrote it down and then the
scribes were like well wait a minute.
If he's a prophet he's getting this from
God but he just said it the same way I
said it then that means I'm a prophet
too. So they would just leave Islam.
So
Yeah, we're just trying to to
show the Muslims that their view of
preservation is flawed and if if usually
Muslims will use that as an argument
against Christianity and they'll say oh
you guys have textual variants in the
Bible. We can't trust the Bible cuz
there's variants. So we're trying to
you know return the tables on them with
that and and then if you come another
time we can actually show you why the
Bible is reliable why you should believe
it's reliable and trust it and that is
is the word of God.
Okay okay sure sure sure.
Got you.
Cool.
So um you've been very respectful and we
always appreciate these conversations.
So yeah we just want to extend our you
know thanks and appreciation to you and
hopefully we can have another discussion
or more discussions in the future.
Um usually it doesn't go like usually
the conversations are kind of like how
they went in the last stream. You saw
how that went. They were Well because
the last stream I was actually I was
actually last stream I was actually
trying to debate because I was talking
to that other guy that steady guy. This
stream I I my intention wasn't to
debate. It was just I wanted to see
exactly what your claim was. Okay
perfect.
So hopefully it's clear. If you want to
come back we can actually debate if
you'd like to.
Yeah but if you want to check the
sources and get everything up
we can do that and we didn't even get
into like contradictions between the
different readings but we have plenty
examples of that as well.
Yeah also so if I come back I mean after
I look into all the sources and I get my
books because I do as I said I'm not
really big on like getting stuff off of
YouTube and stuff like that. I only
I I just have books. I collect books.
It's just a thing but
you know.
That's good. That's good. So the
the goal in this like we're not trying
to insult or disrespect. We're just
trying to show the truth and our end
goal is always discussions is to glorify
God and how we conduct ourselves and
point people to the truth which is
ultimately going to lead you to Jesus.
He is the truth.
So that's that's what I have to say.
Anything you want to say before you go
you can go ahead.
Okay perfect. Uh
Hope you guys have a good day. Um
hopefully
I mean I I try to be respectful, so I'm
glad that you guys
were respectful as well because I do try
to be as patient as I can when I talk to
people, especially non-Muslims. So,
yeah.
Well, Talia, it's been honestly it's
been a pleasure listening to you engage
and stuff like that. Um I knows it was
educational for those listening that's
not too familiar with these subjects, so
thank you for participating and I really
really really do hope that you come back
and continue with Jai and
you know, even refute try to refute him
later.
All good. All good. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. As I said, I mean, today my
intention in this live wasn't to debate
because I can't really
especially I I can't debate on other
people's lives, especially
because every time I try to debate I I
always get cut off, etc. etc. I've never
been on you guys's live before and I try
not to get on people that I don't knows
lives, but you know, I'll look into your
sources. I'll see exactly what your
claims are cuz I was writing everything
down so I could see exactly what you
were saying.
And yeah, I mean, if you want to debate
in the future, we definitely can. Now
now you know us. Now you now you know
how we rock, you know how we engage.
It's just we we prefer this right here,
like this type of
we where we listen to each other, we
exchange, it's you know, if someone
interjects politely, they can interject
or if you like hold on, let me finish
this thought, let them finish the
thought. You know, just regular
conversation, not hyper emotional and
stuff like that, you know what I mean?
There's like Muslims in the chat being
like, yeah, yeah, yeah, you learned your
deen based off of what Christians say.
I'm
not here to debate in the first place. I
debated I came up here not to debate,
but because I was invited to talk about
it, but it's it's been a respectful
conversation. So,
uh have a good day to you guys and
assalamualaikum to everyone in the chat
and please stop takfiring me, bro. I am
a Muslim. I don't know what you're talk
Stop takfiring me, bro. I didn't do
crap.